maintenant maintenant mémoire d'adrien
qui va vous assurez la renommée et c'est
avec qui paraît en 1951 mais c'est un
niveau quand vous travaillez ou tout cas
aucun vous songé depuis bien longtemps
rêvé commencé à 19h même écrit une ligne
ou sous une forme dialoguée à l'ago
guinot en quelque sorte complète
ça m'a pas mis un possible tournant pour
une autre fois qu'il y avait des
passages qui n'était pas si mal que ça
je les jetais vu ses gains sous la forme
d'un essai est condamné parce que ça
demande une érudition peu près près
développer sur un point lyon quelques
points que je n'avais pas pourquoi avez
vous choisi ce personnage devait rien
contre 19 ans je m'étais mis en tête
d'écrire quelque chose sur adrian
évidemment bien entendu j'avais une
telle un jeune touriste qui se promène
dans la ville adrian à l'époque beaucoup
plus belle à l'époque aujourd'hui pour
qu'on n'y avait pas mis les parkings des
buvettes et quelques statues jardin
qu'elle ne mérite peut-être pas des
veaux la sepra douai de prendre où on
les a mises mais je voyais donc ce que
j'imaginais c'était l'empereur les
knicks le premier empereur au fond qui a
été profondément un amateur de la pensée
est d'avis grecs qui se nommer lui-même
fils de laine ils ont attaché d'évoquer
sa retraite somptueux dans la ville
adriana en y repensant ça m'a paru vague
j'ai essayé de d'évoquer toute sa vie ou
une partie de sa vie et là je manque
évidemment d'exploitation nécessaire la
grandeur d'adrien il ya plusieurs
espèces de manière de considérer d'abord
c'est presque un emprunt pacifique on
peut on peut dire qu adrien était
pacifiste il a rendu certaines conquête
pour terminer immédiatement d'hier
il pendant six années de règne une sale
guerre qui était transmis une espèce de
rébellion de guerrila qui n'a pas pu
éviter la guerre de palestine qui tenir
le plus ou moins tu es et pendant les
cinquante ans qu'ils ont subi grâce aux
arrangements qu'il avait pris la paix
romaine a continué à régner enfin avec
quelques petits accrocs par ci par là
donc en 1948 c'était un personnage
passionnant qu'un homme qui disait lui
même qu'il avait remis de l'aveyron
stabiliser le mot face la première
premier élément grandeur le second ckd
rien n'est pas du tout le romain typique
leurs mains d'un front les mois dans
l'est dans la guerre civile de
montherlant brûlante qui assure une
permanence ce n'est pas un homme qui a
été élevé à rome cet art romain de
province une famille venue des bords de
l'adriatique et installé en espagne
depuis des générations
il y avait ils ennuient d'essence lte de
100 ibère ce ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
possible mais en tout cas il y a les
aspects depuis ils sont très différents
celui du romain habituel il est à sa
sobriété
il ya sa passion de la chasse que je
suis humaine partagée mais qui fait déjà
de lui le poids nécessaire des rêves
pour après il est sa passion du bug mais
cette frénésie sombre ceux ci sont
tombés dans la fantaisie et dans le
roman est normal dans la poésie plus
loin mais vinet a pu passer complètement
noir de l'espagne ignatieff
mais tout de même le sol en képi le
deuil pour une impératrice latine
enfin les femmes ne sont pas nécessaires
le seul homme qui a élevé le grand
tombeau un démo du passé et allie aussi
à dix morts deux sont en est le seul
homme qui était un culte ainsi presque
insensé pour un ami mort pendant neuf
ans et si préoccupés de multiplier ses
portraits au point d'un bon look à
personne d'autre de l'antiquité autant
portrait que dans dinos donc il a été un
conte prince hylas ne pas extrader
un individu n'empêche pas les dossards
que adrien termine sa vie sur un échec
est l'échec parce que la révolte de la
palestine qui va l'écraser dans le sens
il a rasé jérusalem a bien su bien sûr
et ça c'est ce que trop peu de gens ont
remarqué
il n'y a eu un énorme une énorme
correspondant aux mamans américain
phénomène traduit s'il ya ce genre de
correspondance par exemple causée par la
publication d'adrien en france et puis
ensuite en anglais et la plupart des
volumes avait aperçu vous voyez adrien
comme une réussite aurait bien entendu à
bria et un bien réussi mais pas du tout
dans les conditions éclatante qu'on
imagine tout d'abord c'est un homme qui
pour arriver au pouvoir a mis 40 ans en
passant par toutes les tous les stages
de discipline militaire et civil il
quelques compromis et probablement même
quelques impostures passe pour obtenir
ne pouvait les capitales ensuite il
s'agit c'est qu'ils tuent aussi sincère
que tel qu'un poulet ce qui ne plaît pas
beaucoup d ensuite une fois arrivé au
pouvoir il ay à ce moment d'activité est
perdu et enfin les joyeuses lorsqu'il
s'aperçoit qu'il peut rétablir la paix
rétabli une situation économique du
monde et très vite on passa l'enivrement
la rencontre habitants chinoise qui
produira présence au dîner à l'humain
très vite produit cette espèce dans
librement les choses vont trop bien
elles m'ont même si bien qu'elles vont
même et l'effondrement se produit au
suicide en terre c'est le second
d'effondrement guerriers on a vu un
premier durant la guerre parce qu'il
avait cru mais qui n'arriveraient pas à
vampire et ensuite il se remet bien sûr
il redevient emprunterait efficient qui
n'était déjà mais il y à un troisième et
font vraiment la guerre de palestine
avec la naïveté con parce que toutes les
nations riches et puissants monde est
supposé ou sommet de la simulation de
leur temps qui se dit persuadé qu'ils
n'avaient qu'à pareille dans palestine
pour persuader les israélites que
il accepterait ces civilisations romaine
et ne l'ont pas acceptée d'où une grande
partie n'a pas accepté et il se trouvait
en fait une épouvantable guerre civile
qui a duré trois ans donc pour une offre
aux pacifistes
c'est un choc mais d'une certaine
manière avec cette dire la partie de ce
complot d'adrien qui participent au
tragique de notre temps nous avons
absolument à 7
et c'est à ce moment là d'ailleurs que
celui montré réfléchissant à la nuit en
se disant que ça c'est très bien que
rome en étant encore à sa belle époque
mais que cette belle époque ne peut pas
y
mais vous dites quelque part jusqu'où
que vous connaissez mieux
adrien que votre père observant parce
que tout de même nous avons pas mal de
notes d'humour assure adrien est vrai
qu'ils sont fragmentaires est il vrai
que beaucoup émane de chroniqueurs mais
york qui ne comprenait pas enfin king
qui s'exhale gérer les choses qui les
voyaient d'une façon est rudimentaire et
naïve comme des journalistes pas très
informé mais elle aura tout de même des
documents non pas sur mon père j'ai un
certain nombre de documents j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de souvenirs vu aussi des
périodes double tandis que la paire
violent et haineux dont vous prouvera
sont très importants dans un personnage
ya pour eux rien une période de pénombre
lorsqu'il n'est jeune officier lorsqu'il
fait la guerre lorsqu'ils acceptent un
produit brut est ainsi bien obligé de le
faire
la politique de son prédécesseur mais
nous savons pas grand chose c'était
parti lui même en quelque sorte la
presque oublié une fois arrivé au
pouvoir
mais c'est tout de même un sérieux dans
lequel nous ne voyons pas dans des
tailles s curieux vous puissiez dire que
vous connaissez mieux un empereur du
deuxième set après jésus-christ que
notre père avait vécu pendant 20 ans et
l'illusion élan qui pensent tous que la
famille dont on est excessivement proche
voyons un peu les choses de près à père
est un monsieur qui vous a eu comme cris
dans mon cas car il avait 45 ans mettons
que j'ai commencé à observer on en avait
7 il en avait donc 52 donc toute sa
jeunesse était derrière lui
j'ai dû reconstituer sa jeunesse par ces
récits qui heureusement était assez
abondant des mulets poser des questions
il y a répondu un peu plus tard à l'âge
de 7 ans évidemment et ensuite il n'ya
le fait que le fait même d'être une
fille fausses ou à fils foncez c'est la
situation l'égard d'un personnage et mon
père et on ne pense pas assez que ce
père est un monsieur bien samedi à lui
ses aventures à lui ses soucis à lui et
qui peut être un très bon père
mais qui veut le fait de la paternité ne
le voit ne le compensent pas entièrement
il ya d'autres éléments qu'on risque
d'oublier mais on ne doit pas vivre
impunément je ne sais j'ose dire avec un
personnage comme adrien pendant vingt
ans sans que je sais pas il vous modifie
le terrain interviennent aux personnes
l'ont maintenu modifie tous nous
apprenons c'est ce qu'il ya un mur de
six faux lorsqu'on s'imagine que un
personnage chez nous si c'était nous y
sommes il serait aussi pauvre que nous
c'est à dire il l'aurait nous mêmes
limites
l'important est d'avoir un personnel qui
nous a pas une quelque chose dont
tempérament dans la vie soit assez
différente pour que nous ayons quelques
cent des rallonges n'ont quà a brillé
vous a modifié la fréquentation de
probablement son attelle du gant c'était
sûrement très intelligent est-ce qu'on
diriez que me adrien ma vie mes mauvais
moins que l'histoire nouveau vous citer
des exemples littéraires parce que ce
sont en quelque sorte des répondants
vous rappelez vous la françois de proust
qui était si impitoyable pour la fille
de cuisine mais quand tu es libre livres
de médecine la description de la maladie
la fille de cuisine d'une maladie était
une grossesse ou d'accouchement à
pleurer à la peau parce que dans la vie
courante enfin nous
nous nos défenses je suppose que le fait
même nous devons continuer à vivre et
qui beaucoup même que la vie pratique
continue nous avons pu sentir le trafic
des événements sauf par moments sans ça
nous serions tous à plat par terre
adrien disent aussi et c'est magnifique
la plus haute forme de vertu la seule
que je supporte encore la ferme
détermination d'être utile là pour moi
ç'a toujours été une idée maîtresse
ça explique peut-être les 40 adhésion à
47 voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils placé dans
un linceul coup j'ai dit ça y est c'est
aussi ces noms belle jusqu'au dernier
moment ne viendra le voir nous verrons
de ceux qui contrôlent et non se
dressent des mythiques modestement utile
et vous c'est une ligne de votre vie et
c'est une ligne aussi